lágrimas en el día más triste del kun
aguero como futbolista profesional
dada esta conferencia es
para comunicarle que
con él he decidido
dejar de jugar al fútbol a sus 33 años
una arritmia cardíaca sufrida el pasado
30 de octubre le obliga a retirarse de
los terrenos de juego una decisión
tomada mano a mano con los doctores de
su actual equipo el fc barcelona- estuve
en buenas manos de los médicos que
que también he hecho lo mejor y me han
dicho que lo mejor era
y dejar de jugar en el camp nou estuvo
acompañado de joan laporta presidente de
la entidad sus compañeros de plantilla y
pep guardiola ex barcelonista y
entrenador de aguero durante su etapa en
el manchester city entre 2011 y 2021 con
este anuncio se acaba una trayectoria
futbolística llena de éxitos tanto en
argentina como en europa facturó
agradecer a todos
independiente qué
de donde me formé después del atlético
madrid que han venido acá
que han apostado por mí con sólo 18 años
han apostado en mí en que puede hacer
las cosas bien en europa
y bueno es la gente el siti abuelo había
llegado esta temporada al barcelona en
donde por fin parecía que jugaría al
lado de su buen amigo leo messi con
quien conquistó la copa américa el
pasado julio el astro argentino ha
tenido en instagram palabras de cariño
para su amigo también el barça que
recordó agüero que siempre formará parte
del club